this is the Jocko underground podcast
number 36. Echo Charles here sitting
with me
still not
100 sure what's going on we're still
we we have to maintain the underground
as you may have heard on the last
version of this we have
is it a war
there have been warlike moves been made
symptoms they're symptomatic symptomatic
of War
so that is why we have the underground
podcast we have experienced some
Acts
some offensive activities from some
groups that control some large media
areas that's why we have this Jocko
underground podcast so Draco
underground.com
if you want to support
we appreciate it
I was thinking the other day
as I observed emotions
negative emotions being evoked in an
individual
anger type frustration
and I I just wanted to talk a little bit
about
controlling your emotions
and I think I I I do control my emotions
and I would say that I have been
controlling my emotions for long enough
now that it is not a big challenge for
me to control my emotions and
specifically I'm I'm talking about anger
frustration things are going to make you
lash out things are making Country Fest
those kind of things
I've been controlling those emotions for
long enough that
I I've got some methodology behind it I
also
got to see many times people
and I still get to see people that lose
their emotional control they get angry
look people get sad sometimes and you
know just to start this thing off I'm
not saying emotions are bad that's not
what I'm saying before you freak out
I'm not saying emotions are bad emotions
are good emotions make us human emotions
are part of life they in fact in many
ways they are life so I'm not saying
emotions are bad but
allowing emotions to dictate the way
you're going to behave allowing emotions
to make to drive your decision-making
process is not going to help you so
here's a couple things that I have in
mind that kind of flow through my mind
when
some when things are happening that
could cause emotions and basically I
barely even get a little blip on the
radar I get a little blip and it's
already I go into this mode that I'm
about to talk about the first one I
automatically think hey whatever I'm
hearing right now is probably wrong
the reason I know that is because on the
battlefield first reports are
first reports are almost always wrong
what do you mean what you're hearing
like in your head or like whatever
whatever input yes I guess whatever
stimulus is hitting me that's about to
make me angry I feel that little blip
whatever I'm saying is probably not
right whatever someone's telling me
whatever I'm hearing whatever I'm seeing
it's probably not right it looks bad but
it's probably not that bad the reason I
know that is because on the battlefield
you're gonna get some report that comes
in and people are it someone's panicking
it's gonna sound horrible
and it's probably not accurate doesn't
mean you dismiss it but you don't get
emotional you don't get emotional
because you're dealing with some other
people's emotions because when you send
me a report back from the battlefield
and you just got your your OverWatch
position just got shot up you're
freaking heated we just got shot up okay
do I immediately send the qrf the quick
reaction for us no I go hey Roger
give me a little bit more detail what's
happening so I'm gonna I'm gonna not get
emotional
the reason I'm not going to get
emotional is because I can almost
guarantee you that the continued
amplifying information that's going to
come my way
is going to mitigate some of the problem
just by Nature
the second thing that I kind of think
about is whatever is happening right now
whatever I'm hearing whatever I'm seeing
is not final
a lot of people jump to the conclusion
of whatever's happening right now is the
is the ultimate atrocity situation the
disaster the catastrophic scenario
that's what people immediately go
through mentally
and for me
things never seem catastrophic to me
ever I was almost ever right look can
you have
a cat I'll tell you uh there was an
explosion up in Maine up in Farmington
Maine at one of the factories up there
not a non-origin factory thank God
but
there was a massive massive explosion in
a mill
and
I've talked to Pete Pete like called me
and he he's like dude this thing is gone
like the Factory's gone and I just knew
so something like that I know
immediately this is a catastrophic
situation
whoever was in there is dead this is
horrible
and
so but but that's very rare you know
even in my in my military career like
hey this is what happened with a vehicle
gets hit with an IED okay
there's a chance it's catastrophic for
sure but if my immediate response is
emotional
when chances are okay we're gonna get
more information we're going to find out
exactly what happened
my emotional response
is not going to help me make good
decisions so so I don't think
catastrophic out of the gate
because that doesn't help me process
what's happening doesn't mean I dismiss
it and think it couldn't be catastrophic
but I don't focus on the
catastrophicness of the situation by the
way if it's catastrophic guess what it
doesn't matter you you've already missed
it's already gone it's already
catastrophic so you can't you can't take
that back so getting emotional about
something that you can't take back is
not going to help you move forward right
now
because those emotions aren't going to
help me make decisions
my viewpoint is that if I lose my temper
it's weak and I seeing leaders when I
was a kid in the SEAL Teams seeing a
leader lose their temper
and just looking at them in a
you know like a
demeaning way of patheticness like wait
a second you're getting mad that's
what's happening you're gonna yell and
scream
and I I just remember seeing that
throughout my career but especially when
I was young I see some leader yell and
scream and just think this person is an
idiot
so I'm never gonna do that I'm never
gonna yell and scream so that's another
thing I kind of run through my mental
checklist
I don't want to
I don't want to give you control by the
way Echo over what I'm doing over what
I'm thinking over my emotional state so
you come in and you say something
and I don't want to give you control
over my mental state so this is another
little mental check I say wait a second
am I Really Gonna Let Echo make me fly
off the handle right now that's where
I'm at no I'm not gonna do that that's a
bad move
it's kind of a pathetic move
so we're not doing it
[Applause]
it doesn't help
for me to give away my position
leadership strategy and tactics what
gives away my position
my emotions
you come in and you say I don't like the
way this plan is looking and I
immediately get mad I'm giving away my
position
I don't want to give away my position
because once I give away my position now
you know where I'm at and I can't move
anymore
so when someone would come with some
idea to me
or come on some attack to me attack me
about something
you'd never be able to tell that I was
even remotely frustrated by it or anger
or whatever I'm just sort of like hey
give me some details on that
not you know look do I do some reflect
and diminish yes I don't I just act like
Mr Robot no I'm not saying act like a
robot
but I'm not going to get overly
emotional in these situations
and so so the I guess those are kind of
some things that go through my mind that
have been going through my mind for a
long time starting when I was a young
seal realizing that watching a leader
lose his mind and get all mad and
realizing how weak and pathetic that was
and how this and how the level of
respect would go down
made me realize getting emotional is not
good now like I said before this doesn't
mean that you don't have emotions and it
doesn't mean this is even more important
doesn't mean that you don't put emotions
into the calculus of what's happening
because if you're getting emotional
about something
and I say don't I don't take that into
account I I'm gonna throw things off
here's a great example when Mark Lee got
killed
when Mark Lee got killed Ryan Jobe got
horribly wounded and that was with late
Splatoon Charlie platoon on the other
side of ramadi Seth had his platoon and
they had a uh an operation for that
night
and
I talked to Seth and I was like hey man
you're good to go for tonight meaning he
was thinking like hey I was thinking he
was thinking hey you're gonna stand down
because we had a guy you know Mark's
Mark got killed where are we going to
stand down for a couple days are you
guys going to come over here we're gonna
do a service form like what are we gonna
do and I I just said hey man you're good
to go for tonight you can go and conduct
your operation
and Seth like sent me uh there's this
thing called Webby which is like a way
of communicating it's basically like
like um like a little chat room and he's
like hey negative on the mission tonight
and I was like no hey you're good to go
man you can you're cleared hot like you
can go and he's like uh negative on the
mission
and so I was like no bro I got like you
got authorized we're good
I I talked up the chain of command we
can still execute this thing
and he called me he was like bro
we're not going out and I was like I was
like you can go if he goes hey man if I
take the guys out right now it's gonna
get bad
and I knew exactly what he was talking
about no we just had we just lost one of
our guys you put the boys out and
they're gonna they're gonna
they're they're gonna be too emotional
so I had to take the emotions of the
situation into account
and if you don't take the emotions into
account then you can end up in a bad
situation as well so it's not that
emotions should be ignored it's not that
emotion it's not that you shouldn't be
emotional but you need to have
control over your emotions that doesn't
mean you shut them out means you have
control over them and you and you
account for them and you put them in the
calculus with other people and with
yourself
that's what I got it's good yep you know
when people lose and you talk about this
where it's like it feels powerful you
know like when if I get mad and that's
when you think about it and tell me tell
me if you'd regard this the same way the
same thing you know like name dropping
right it's one of those things where if
you do it you know of course I'm I'm
achieving my goal of letting these
people know I'm important for
associating with this person but when
someone else does it it's kind of call
you freaking name dropper so obvious
right isn't that like when people like
have outraged like anger outbursts isn't
it kind of the same thing because like
when someone else is doing it you're
like bro this guy's freaking flying off
the handle like a but when you're
doing it you're like they're probably
thinking like oh oh that goes freaking
losing it right now man this is heavy
you know like kind of a thing yeah I I
think you're right but also there's also
there's also people that lose their mind
and they're not thinking anything they
literally are freaking losing their mind
and and that's the worst right hey if
you're like doing a little calculation
and acting mad to try and intimidate or
trying to whatever that's one thing it
always feels like that's part of the
equation I don't know maybe I'm around
the wrong people but but but yes that I
think it's a scale I think it's a
Continuum right because there are some
people let's face it you've seen some
people in your life that have completely
lost their mind and the loss of temper
and there you can't stop them they're
going crazy you can't hold them back or
you have to hold them back
that is a little excerpt of what we are
doing on the Jocko underground podcast
so if you want to continue to listen go
to Jocko underground.com And subscribe
and we're doing this to mitigate our
Reliance on external platforms so we are
not subject to their control and we're
doing it so we can give you more control
more interaction more direct connections
better Communications with us
strengthen this Legion of Troopers that
are in the game with us so thank you
it's Jocko underground.com it cost eight
dollars and 18 cents a month and if you
can't afford to support us we can still
support you just email assistance Jocko
underground.com and we'll get you taken
care of until then we will see you
mobilized
Underground